you were
so good oh my god no no no no you're
being kind no i'm not being kind no
no i okay i am canadian and i'm very
nice but no you killed it do you feel
good i feel
crazy i feel like my mind is on fire
like it's one of them like come down
here i don't i definitely knock them
down yet
okay what were you more nervous to do
the snl opening or the opening here at
the junos that's oh my god that's such a
great question i think i was more
nervous anxious for snl and i was
nervous excited for the junior oh that's
good
when you're in snl first of all you know
we're in 30 rock it's amazing building
iconic heritage but then you're like
you're led behind like backstage and
it's this tiny little dark area and and
you're just basically sitting there
watching the snl credits roll and you're
on that stage and you're like that's a
lot you're crapping your pants
with the junos is so different there's
so many people out there everyone's
excited everyone's smiling i mean it was
just impossible not to get swept away by
the internet it's true and so much
canadian pride in your speech it was so
good
oh i'm i'm so glad that we got to do it
and um i think you know there were a lot
of important things that needed to be
said and i'm glad that we got the
message out there it was amazing listen
you were so smooth out there but was
there anything going on backstage that
we didn't know about did you fall did
you slip wardrobe malfunction something
going on was everything really that
smooth did you fall did you slip did it
that's my new wrap that's the
the thing that comes to mind is i just
as you can probably hear like my voice
is is kind of fried okay and so i think
i was just popping lozenges backstage
and just going and like guzzling
the hot tea which is never a good idea
yeah trying to like save my voice so i
was just in the background going because
i knew i had to you know and you know i
like the bit was to play guitar and sing
like kind of ironically yeah but you
still kind of want to do it like yeah
you wanna you don't you know you're in
front of all these musicians yeah you're
fun like you don't want to just be the
total stress so you know i'm like in the
back corner like you know what i'm
probably in a pot like doing the most
basic chords meanwhile you got like you
know arcade fire and arkells right it's
just like
rip it i'm like what's a g chord okay
listen your air guitar skills right now
are so impressive so y'all again
that's amazing
you